we got choppers now wait 11 sitting down
a chopper with mine
volume 2 of stranger things managed to
pack everything we love about the series
into two compact little episodes we're
taking a look inside the hive mind at
how they managed to pull off their most
intense episodes to date it's gonna feel
very different it's gonna feel very big
it'll be like season one you know on
steroids or something number one it's no
secret that the cast of stranger things
is top-notch well our favorite cast of
kids uh young adults are also phenomenal
improvisers from witty quotable new
lines to subtle little changes the
urgency and honesty these actors bring
is next level like caleb mclaughlin
crying out to his sister there we go
it's a sweet and tragic moment of
vulnerability for lucas another pretty
super moment was finn's improvisation
during his monologue which he only
needed to shoot a few times by the way
because he's a true pro you're my
superhero and the brotherly love is in
the air between eddie munson and dustin
henderson
this tear-jerking moment was all gut
instinct our stuff together is is so
poignant and important to driving his
character
number two behind the scenes of the
creel house had far fewer tripping
hazards it's like hopscotch over
imaginary vines trying to step around
all those vines was less dramatic
because they weren't there the actors
were just trying to hit their mark in
other words tape on the floor there was
no rope or anything standing in for the
vines so when robin was strung up
against the wall maya was just having to
hold her arms in the air for a very long
time joe broke the freaking camera
during one take because he had to swing
an axe close to it but accidentally
struck it went directly into camera
through this filter into the front and
the shot was amazing number three did
you know that the voice of vechna is all
real don't believe us just check out
jamie campbell bower in the recording
booth i saw a means to realize my
potential
unlike how daker montgomery had his
voice altered and changed adding a
little unsettling and ominous tone when
he was taken over by the mind player now
we can all see you
jamie's voice was all his to transcend
my human form
there was no need for jaime to transcend
his human form
all i needed was someone to open the
door and he did that for me number four
thanks to extra time we got a ton of
eddie joseph quinn knows his way around
a guitar but they did have another
guitarist to come in and do that epic
solo regardless eddie munson's fate
wasn't always tied to his guitar but as
they talked about his ending it became
clear it's what they needed to do they
were able to go back to earlier episodes
because none of them had been shot yet
and layer in the guitar layer in his
band usually they write about four
scripts and are already shooting as the
next chunk of scripts are being written
joseph quinn was pretty gutted when he
found out they were quite literally
gutting his character but it was one
epic send-off and he couldn't really be
mad about that the most surprising or
surreal part of
fan experience number five what seemed
like a simple shot still took a very
long time matt duffer said we were very
much inspired by empire strikes back
that ending where they're looking out
the window we wanted to hint at the
notion of war and a supernatural war
coming to hawkins the cast and crew
spent an entire super hot day out there
just to get this one shot the most
exhausting thing but doing it together
was the best number six we know what
you're thinking how was this show disney
inspired well the inspiration for the
creel house was actually the haunted
mansion ride from disneyland because
sean levy doesn't enjoy horror they gave
him the required viewing list in
addition to a music playlist so he did
have a crash course in horror haunted
house fluency abilities we have as
storytellers have grown every year
number seven flipping stereotypes on
their head was the goal the writer's
room really enjoyed taking characters
and then doing role reversals playing
against the stereotypes humanizing
people like eddie munson and chrissy you
don't remember me
i'm sorry of course this has been going
on since season one the actors are
really grateful for this as well because
it has led to such interesting and
dynamic characters we're the freaks
because
we like to play a fantasy game number
eight honestly we might have just turned
the tv off if they did in max for good
they had a ton of discussions about what
they wanted to do but it became very
important for season five that max be in
a coma this season was influenced
heavily by empire strikes back of course
and so max's coma was an attempted
parallel to han solo being frozen in
carbonite do you think that came across
at all
come here max
number nine sometimes the nonsensical
offing of characters heads just isn't
necessary the russian doublecrosser enzo
almost met a tragic fate in a previous
draft of the script but honestly there
was no reason for it it didn't move the
plot along so why not give this guy his
happy ending too and more star wars
references the demo bats were inspired
by the parasitic minok bats in the
empire strikes back in an earlier draft
the demo bats had serrated tail
tentacles that were meant to wrap and
then cut flesh if they had this trait
they could have too easily killed steve
another design was way too similar to
the demo dogs and demogorgons because
its head and body split open the same
way i really like that stuff and as the
show has gone on i've gotten to do more
and more of it number 10. crafting the
big baddie is always time-consuming work
vecna went through a ton of different
concept art the first designed to haunt
your nightmares is the one of him with
hair and a pathetic excuse for a face
you can see the evolution of one idea
from the initial fish inspiration to
giving him a spiky coat of armor the
praying mantis design is awesome but it
wasn't exactly a practical design for
filming either because of its long legs
and the duffer brothers were really
leaning towards vekna being practical
the alien designs were direct
inspiration from the demogorgons and
demo dogs and would have tied him in
aesthetically with the rest of the
upside down creatures these designs
while amazing in theory just didn't
disguise henry well enough or didn't
allow for enough expression move my
fingers around really slow i'm moving
them fast enough because i'm excited
number 11. floating rocks it's too
complicated
at one point the particles were going to
be harvested from floating rocks it had
a lot to do with how gravity worked
differently in this realm but it was too
lengthy to try and explain would you
like to join them
probably the coolest alternate design
for vecna's lair was a later one more in
line with the spider theme where his
victims were hanging from the vine like
it was a spider web
he could not change us
number 12. it's got to be a great
feeling when some of the greats want to
work with you robert englund sent in an
audition tape of himself lying in a
bathtub fully clothed mind you pouring
his heart out so no it wasn't the
stranger things team's idea to bring in
freddy krueger but it was a perfect
pairing
number 13 the stranger things cast are
just so melodramatic we actually went on
a 45 minute walk that day do you
remember the day in question was the end
for 11's papa they walked all the way
from the base camp through the middle of
the desert because they were sad millie
did love the boldness of eleven to not
wrap up her complicated relationship
with her papa by giving him what he
wanted in those last moments
[Music]
number fourteen the style of the show
still throws the actors for a loop a lot
of the time they're thinking okay so
we're about to face this big bad evil
thing we're scared right and the duffer
brothers are like yeah
like like you're pretty confident the
levity in the characters is really just
rejuvenating for the actors who if they
were stuck in a place of constant terror
might just find the show not so fun to
film number 15. we're not talking about
vechna's clocks but netflix's they were
cutting it close to time with adding the
final vfx actually their time was so bad
that if you tuned in to watch volume 2
right upon release there were a few vfx
shots that weren't done yet and people
were encouraged not to watch until the
morning when they would be complete did
you binge watch the entire two episodes
of volume 2 let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things